I really love the Elder Scrolls series
Elder Scrolls games have always been
complex RPGs with interesting quests
immersive worlds and a series of stories
that let you become the toughest
scariest badass in the known realm I've
been playing Elder Scrolls games since
daggerfall when I was first able to
independently work a pc when Skyrim was
released I was a university student and
every spare second I didn't absolutely
have to be elsewhere I was playing this
game that's real world elsewhere not
Tamriel elsewhere I was even cautiously
optimistic about the arrival of Elder
Scrolls online but the way its MMO
transformation squashed my fantasy of
being Tamriel one and only hero kinda
killed the fun for me now we've got the
beta of Elder Scrolls legends a
hot-stone esque online card game and I'm
here to answer the question does elder
scrolls legends have any appeal to fans
of the Elder Scrolls franchise I've
briefly played hearthstone and dabbled
with magic the gathering but not since
Martin Magic's addictive and excellent
arkham age has a card game really
grabbed my attention here's the basics
of the legend später the matches take
place within a couple of lanes on the
playing table these can be affected by
different statuses like wind which
randomly moves the card to another Lane
at the end of the turn you can only
attack creatures in the same Lane as you
or the other player there's a rune
system that gives you cards as you take
damage which is sort of an equalizer and
you can build decks that range from 50
to 70 cards it's also the opportunity to
upgrade cards as you go to make them
stronger but let's talk about the draw
cards for Elder Scrolls fans punk not
totally intended to begin with you
actually get to pick from 10 familiar
races when you start and the race you
pick affects the kind of cards you'll
unlock later on for example Nords are
more likely to get offensive cards you
will however collect all sorts of decks
from other races as you play you'll
recognize a bunch of familiar faces on
the cards and hear sound bites from the
series including a guard who used to be
an adventurer like you I used to be an
adventurer
there's also familiar foes like Daedra
and callbacks to everybody's least
favorite racist faction at the old Mary
Dominion one of Bethesda selling points
to elder scrolls fans has been that the
full story mode is framed through the
completion of quests to this I'll say
sort of what happens is your fights each
chapter are contextualized a room in the
forest will lead you to facing off
against a deck filled with Wolf cards
and a confrontation on the high seas
will have you battling against pirate
cards occasionally Legends gets closer
to the vibe of the main series as you're
offered a moral choice related to the
story for example whether you want to
execute or spare a bandit who attacked
you where this fails is that you're
actually elect in which card you want
with this choice generally I choose
Paragon options but the card offered up
for the kill option was way better so
bye-bye bandit the next time it asked me
whether to adopt or abandon a baby wolf
I ignored the good card and I adopted
the little bugger because I'm only human
or in this case dark elven at this stage
the choice only appears to have an
impact on your deck and not the way the
story progresses the cutscenes between
chapters that explain where you're
headed next and why enhance the feeling
that you're making progress through the
plot that said enhancing isn't quite the
same as capturing that feeling at the
end of the day this is first and
foremost a card game and no amount of
Elder Scrolls fandom is going to get you
through it if you don't have at least a
little love for the digital card game
genre I personally found the dialog to
be super cheesy and the story mildly
involving but for what its offering
Legends is the most enjoyable when it
capitalizes on its core mechanics like
lanes and tactical decision making with
minor injections of more complicated
features like status effects and new
card abilities that make you alter your
tactics it is always satisfying to watch
a board turning in your favor you will
definitely find yourself smirking here
and there because you got that reference
or remember that character but if
building decks and engaging in turn
based card warfare isn't your thing you
may want to hold out until the
elder scrolls six
you